I was reading this Artic article about
skull and bones and skull and bones
sucks now Skull and Bones used to be
like you know the leaders of America
it's still that but everyone
sucks because the the they're they're
doing like diversity equity and
inclusion in the Illuminati in Skull and
Bones which is used to be just let's get
a bunch of people that show that they
can carry
on uh the tradition of being a sociopath
that's what scullin bones is about it's
like finding rich people that have skill
set that makes them look like maybe that
maybe hey maybe they could be
sociopaths and it's it's in at Yale
University the CIA started it was taken
right out of skull and bones okay so
many uh bonesmen have risen to positions
of prominence and power the you know
presidents CE EOS we get it a lot of
white guys lot of white guys they would
jerk off in the coffins it was very like
Nazi I think George W bush stole jono's
skull and it was in the Tomb and there's
all this secret in the Tomb and now it's
like annoy they're annoying now now it's
like they're annoying they literally in
the Skull and Bones tomb like took down
all the pictures of the old white guys
because it's it was not diverse can you
imagine getting into Skull and Bones the
most elite sanctum and then going God
this God does this suck I mean it is
like and by the way they don't take
whites anymore they're not taking a lot
of white people they take like only a
few whites they take a lot of minorities
who are the first person in their family
to go to
college this is what skull and bones is
doing the first generate like it's like
it's like a it's
insane like someone that gets tapped the
way Skull and Bones works is when you're
a junior at Yale or something you get
tapped or maybe maybe it's seniors
seniors get tapped into it what I don't
know I'm not in it
okay and and that's not where the real
power is anymore the P the power is not
in that it's not these people at Yale
anymore and we'll go into who it is but
it's they have some of it but they're
losing it all the time they're losing it
all the time but you get tapped into
this and then you got to go through this
initiation and then you're in this thing
and it's all it's all like
people that are annoying
now except they want all the benefits of
that power structure they want to get
jobs they want to make lots and lots of
money but they they want to like
go like like like like these
colonizers but they're in the thing
they're like in the thing they just want
to make they're like we're going to make
this Elite Society of uh rich people
good we're GNA make it good it's it's
it's this is how
stupid our
political realities are at the moment
this is how how these kids brains have
been
melted they're in this inner sanctum
they call it a tomb it's like a the
tombs right and they're and they're
there and they're going we want to be
elite rich people that cover each
other's backs but we we we want to like
also we want to make it good we want to
do it for the right reasons and it's
like the most
psychotic thing and by the way you read
about all these other societies where
they all go we're going to give all the
money back to New Haven they don't do
any of that they just hang out they're
college kids they're all I don't care
how smart you think you are you're an
idiot when you're 18 you're an idiot
you're all idiot and I know people are
out there going like yeah yeah yeah but
they got into Yale Tim and you dropped
out of nasau Community College okay yeah
but I'm in Santa Barbara lot aren't
I so what
happens to these people are at the peak
of their idealism and and and and
they're going into these old uh
institutions that are yes of course
they're racist and all the bists of it's
the skull and bone society and all these
people go in there and they all have
this idea that they're going to be
different they're going to change it
they're going to use it for good I'm
using skull and bones for good but they
all just become rich Pricks that's all
it is that's all skull and bones is you
just become rich prick I don't care that
you're you're a
biracial
bisexual nonbi it doesn't matter you'll
be all of those things in addition to
being a rich
prick who's trying to get ahead based on
the fact that you know other Rich Pricks
is what it is and I'm not saying I'm not
even hating on that there's just such an
in say instead of just scrapping it just
scrap it just get rid of it if you
really don't like it don't be in it say
no when they tap you go no not for me
I'm GNA do it on my own but none of
these scumbags want to do it on their
own you know like people like like me or
Trish pis have
done but none of these
scumbags want to do it on their own they
all want benefits of being in little
cabal but they just want the cabal to be
arranged around the things that they
think are more uh altruistic of better
things it's so
stupid message me if you're in Skull and
Bones by the way it's hilarious it's
it's not Elite anymore no one cares you
losers no one cares you broke hoes